Democrats have lost another special
election making them oh and for in the
Donald Trump era this was in the sixth
District of Georgia last night this was
the spot vacated by Tom Price after
being appointed Secretary of HHS by
Donald Trump John
aasif announced his candidacy for this
special election back in January he was
endorsed by some pretty prominent
figures congressman Hank Johnson John
Lewis State House Democratic Leader
Stacey Abrams in Georgia raised over 8
million dollars and this is a widely
considered the most expensive house race
in the history of all House races a sort
of referendum on Trump in some way right
this was a major uphill battle Tom Price
the the prior seat holder there one with
a two-to-one margin many many times
that's when he was opposed sometimes
unopposed with nearly 100 percent of the
vote
this is a major red Republican district
and indeed aasif loss we have the
election results from last night karen
handel
with 51 point nine percent of the vote
besting John Asif who had forty eight
point one percent of the vote now there
are many on the Left who were split
about the results here Pat there are
some who are saying even with Trump in
the 30s in popularity we still can't get
a win in this special election others
saying hey you know what this is a
really red district and the fact that he
even got 48% of the vote is already a
big deal so what is the good news the
good news is this is as close as a
Democrat has come to winning Georgia six
district in a very very very long time
and better than Hillary Clinton's vote
share in the 6th district which was
46.8%
in November of 2016 what's the bad news
the bad news is number one even though
money helps you win this was a crazy
amount of money for a house race and
also still lost even with the president
with a 30-something percent approval
rating and this is sort of referendum on
the president but but this really
relates more to a broader issue I've
been talking about Pat which is how
we're Democrats going to win
20:18 austin was basically you know
between a progressive democrat and a
blue dog democrat not unusual in terms
of what we're going to see in a lot of
districts in 2018 and 2020 and he you
know opposes prison sentences for
nonviolent drug offenses offenses he
supports abortion rights and access to
contraception
he doesn't want tax increases he's
called for reducing taxes on small
business but at the same time he accepts
the signs of climate change sort of up
what you would expect to see running in
many districts as a Democrat is this
going to work in 2018 and 2020 again the
good news is that this Democrat got a
lot of the vote in a very very red
district compared to what other
Democrats have gotten I still believe
that this needs to be a issues driven
midterm and ultimately 2020 for
Democrats there was not that much Trump
rhetoric from either the winner nor the
loser in Georgia six district but I
think there's a lot to learn here yeah I
think that's why this race is really a
microcosm in a sense because if
Democrats are going to win back the
house in 2018 certainly they'll be a lot
easier than the Senate they'd not only
have to hold their ground but also pick
up 40 to 50 seats currently held by
Republican that's right and it seems as
if now Republicans can body slam
reporters and still win their election
well so there's two sides to see it
right one is you've got a Republicans
body slamming their reporters and still
winning you've got a very unpopular
president and a special election that
had record money raised by the Democrat
still losing the other side though is
you almost lost a very red district if
you're a Republican and you see this and
your takeaway is hay hasta flossed
everything is fine good luck in 2018
because this was a red district a
district that's been red for decades
that you did almost lose and that's with
Trump at 38% approval it Trump's at 30%
approval and you've got 435 of these
districts up for grabs in 2018 you
might not be so lucky this one this red
district you won by two points
you could lose a number of red districts
by two points as well and the whole
reason that we're having these special
elections to begin with is because these
republican congressmen are going to work
in trump's administration right so of
course he's picking republicans and you
know it gives this idea that the
democrats are owing for but that's going
to be an uphill battle in every single
one of those race that's why I'm not
panicking the way some Democrats are
panicking which is these were these were
long shots right these were really long
shot special elections and the reason
why they were even vacant is part of the
story as well